gouvernement qui pressent toujours donc
un peu plus à la vaccination est alors
que 1400 salariés du secteur de la santé
sont suspendus pour non vaccination une
employée d'hôpital attaque aujourd'hui
en justice cette décision devant le
tribunal de versailles où l'on retrouve
tout de suite notre reporter katia
technique pour plus de précisions
[Musique]
bonjour katia alors expliquez nous quel
est le contexte de cette audience
je relis vie alors c'est une audience en
référé au tribunal administratif de
versailles devant lequel je me trouve
elle concerne la suspension de postes de
cette soignante christelle c dont vous
parliez une adjointe administrative du
groupe hospitalier nord-essonne elle a
donc déposé cette requête est
aujourd'hui la cour doit statuer sur la
nécessité et l'urgence de sa mise à
l'écart son avocat espère qu'elle sera
réintégré est également que son cas va
faire jurisprudence
d'ailleurs il dispose d'une vingtaine de
dossiers qui n'a pas pu regrouper il
s'interroge sur cette raison parce que
ailleurs ça peut se faire et puis
bientôt il y aura également une audience
sur le fond alors dans le même temps ce
conseil a déposé une question
prioritaire de
constitutionnalité qui s'appelle donc la
qpc et cela permet lors d'un procès
d'examiner le fait qu'une disposition
législative porte atteinte aux droits
garantis par la constitution évidemment
c'est une qpc qui est relative à
l'obligation vaccinale cette qpc n'a pas
été jugé on va faire aussi un point sur
les soignantes qui comme comme
christelle c'est ont été suspendus il
s'agit de 1400 salariés des hôpitaux des
ehpad et des cliniques cela occasionne
un véritable casse-tête dans les
établissements qui sont comme on le sait
en tension et puis cela signifie aussi
qu'ils sont toujours liés à leur
employeur même s'ils ne sont pas payés
ne peuvent donc pas travailler ailleurs
certains d'entre eux comme christelle on
conscient contester cette suspension
dans le haut-rhin deux soignants
également dans le puy-de-dôme une
vingtaine de soignants qui avait à
déposer des référés bien ont vu leur
requête rejetée il y a encore des cas
pour des jugements à besançon le juge
des référés devrait rendre sa décision
aujourd'hui concernant dix autres
soignants et une petite manifestation de
soutien est prévu merci beaucoup qu'elle
tient pour toutes ces précisions katia
technique en direct devant le tribunal
administratif de verre sayah